[Musique]
au rythme des percussions et du maloya
les conseillers départementaux jeunes de
la réunion accueillir les délégations
métropolitaine de l'association
nationale des conseils d'enfants et de
jeunes venus spécialement sur notre île
pour célébrer les 30 ans du cdj j'étais
très content que joie qui vous ça y est
la vente en fuite ensemble la magie du
moment donc la semaine des trente ans ça
une semaine riche en émotions
j'ai hâte de d'apprenants vous connaître
parce qu'on aura l'occasion d'échanger
tous ensemble il ya cette délégation qui
rompt qui ont répondu présents pour
participer à notre manifestation
d'envergure
donc il ya l'allier le tarn les pyrénées
orientales
il ya le pari le nord
il ya d'autres régions voilà il ya cette
délégation au total et ils sont à peu
près une trentaine de personnes la
première journée des changes s'est tenue
dans l'hémicycle du département où a été
salué l'engagement de tous ces jeunes
dans les actions qu'ils mènent au sein
de leurs conseils les en 30 ans et près
de 4000 jeunes réunionnais qui ont pu
évoluer au sein du cd j ai porté plus de
130 actions de sensibilisation pendant
trois jours ils vont échanger sur des
thèmes d'actualité comme la place du
jeune dans la vie citoyenne et à l'école
sur le terrain est conscient des
réalités
c'est pour cela qu'aujourd'hui soit un
vol pour représenter les jeunes à
problèmes et leurs alliés
[Musique]